[Music]
hello
my name is peter evangelados
i play thor on the hit series stargate
sg-1 you know
for many years i have played this role
for many years i have sought glory and
fame
for many years it has
eluded me
i am saddened by this
however this award
verifies
that the fans have good taste
and of course some of them taste good
too if you know what i mean
perhaps you don't
if you accept my invitation for a date
maybe you will know
anyway all seriousness aside i would
like to thank all the canadian people
who voted us for the second year in a
row yes that's two years in a row
this wonderful trophy it is wonderful as
you can see
very colorful
very unique
very
chic as you know
i would like to thank space a wonderful
wonderful channel
so wonderful i can't stand it you know
most importantly however
all seriousness aside again
i would like to thank the fans
the fans of science fiction in general
and especially the fans of space
time space
that burning sensation
all of you with hemorrhoids you know
what i mean
is there any inner voice that would like
to say something to me no no
ah my inner voices they sound like
tiny little farts
thank you all for this award two years
in a row
two
can you believe it can anybody believe
it
i have no more inner voices
i am so alone
in fact i'm so alone you could call me
lonely
hello hello
i'm richard dean anderson this is
what's the name
i'm amanda tapping
and i'm lawrence fishburn
you are
wow yeah uh we would like to thank you
all um uh long-windedly for the award
that you have bestowed upon us
and our good friend peter here who
works for scale
although as you can tell we've scraped
them off you know
oi i'm dying here
um thank you all very much for these uh
the the second award you've given us the
first one we can't find so it's nice to
be able to
cut cut i need another one
congrats richard
[Music]